back once again doing it live
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
what up y'all welcome back to River with
Griffin everybody in chat everybody
listening later listening live uh
listening in the past in the future
whatever thanks for being here on
riffing with Griffin
I saw Guardians of the Galaxy man I
loved it
NBA playoffs
got news and notes John Morant waving a
gun again and there's a bunch of other
crazy news stories but it's
authentically me and welcome back
[Music]
man I should have uh
should have drank some water before I
started
but welcome to riffing with Griffin uh
thanks for being here y'all I always
appreciate it y'all are great so as you
know you can hit the Subscribe button
make sure you hit that subscribe button
so you could uh be a part of all the
magic every single week daily on Twitch
Eric Griffin gaming so come check me out
there you could be a subscriber there if
you want to support me financially like
that same thing with patreon so come
check me out there too if you want to
help out in in terms of that way it
keeps the show going I appreciate you
guys greatly for being here on the show
ripping with Griffin
with me with Griffo
within with Griffey on you know I got
one of my favorite shirts on I used to
be a people person but
but people ruined it for me
you know it is what it is thanks like I
say thank you for being here thank you
for being a friend
appreciate you guys greatly uh as always
thanks a lot
um let's see what else what's going on
um I don't know nothing really going on
this week nothing too major happening
this week so you know just regular we're
from We're from with Griffin stuff
regular Eric Griffin life stuff uh oh by
the way uh so um I not a lot going on in
May in terms of stand up out of town but
June June I am back at it
so in June wait let me look at my
calendar on my phone so I'm gonna be in
Huntsville and
um what do you call it
thank you Janine Huntsville
and in June and um uh Nashville
so on June let's see when is it
when is it good grief where am I going
oh here we go
so June 21st I'll be at Zanies it's a
Wednesday night one show in Zanies and
then for the weekend I will be in
Huntsville Alabama at stand up live
so Zanies on the 21st so come check me
out there and then a bunch of other
stuff coming up after that I'm gonna be
an improv in Arlington Texas
July June 30th to the 2nd
um I'm gonna be at the Visalia theater
actually June 1st I believe it is our
third yeah June 3rd up in Visalia
California at the Fox Theater I think
it's called yeah the Fox Theater
uh so come check me out there that's
just one night Fox Theater I don't I
don't have a link for the tickets and
stuff like that but you can figure it
out if you really if you're in that area
so come check me out there and that's
June 3rd and I might be in Vegas
excuse me 17th and 18th at the Palms but
I don't know I haven't said yes to that
gig yet so anyways there's stuff coming
up so make sure you uh check me out if
you want to come see me live I am
hilarious okay so come check me out
there okay let's go to comments from the
you know episodes from my YouTube
comments thanks everybody for commenting
uh let's see I never get the names right
honestly saying five five four seven uh
you know people still love
when Bobby Lee and Steve Lee were on my
podcast and we were doing movie reviews
I mean people are still looking at those
episodes which is great that's over a
year I think two years even and then
somebody said wish they made this movie
review a regular podcast with these
three I mean you know people just get
busy you know life moves in different
directions Bobby's doing bad friends and
tiger belly and he's just busy it just
it just didn't work out that way so it
is what it is but I appreciate you guys
watching uh Franco avelia said told you
Boston Griffin imma get to that I'm
gonna get to it so we will talk NBA but
yeah Boston pulled it out
um I'm not even I'm surprised and not
surprised you know what I mean and I'll
explain later as we get to it
um
let's see here what else we got here
oh no don't like any of these
Mario Flores I love your intro so much
bro thank you
uh let's see what else we got here
um
uh crucial everyday carry I can't
imagine Eric with 20 million dollars he
would never take his new hats off with
with 20 million sitting in his bank
account
laughs
yep I would be permanent hat guy
you give me 20 million I'm out I'm just
a hat man hat Man Forever uh let's see
um
somebody said Stephen Beck 1665. 10
still is too much for our to-go tip I
used to work at it to go at restaurant
and tips were greatly appreciated but
pay them pay them pay the people more
don't make the customer's job to give
them more money yeah I mean Mike you
know what I kind of feel that way about
like that
that thing too it's like how did that
happen how did it turn out that like
businesses are like yeah we're not going
to pay our employees
uh we're gonna make you pay them it's
like it's a weird that just that just
seems like a weird I don't know how that
started and why it's continued you know
what I mean
um
so let's see uh what else we got here
uh Brooke Durham eight two four four
thank you Eric for pointing out nuanced
as your favorite word I always say to
myself when you say it if you're ever
looking for a word I say you mean
nuanced
uh that is my favorite word I gotta get
some nuanced merch you know some
reaching out to people where you are to
say you want to help me out I need some
Nuance to merch you know I just need
some merch you know I need I need to
like I have merch you know if you guys
want to go to my mer I have I still have
but it's old I look at everybody else
they're always coming out with some new
stuff but it's just like you know I
gotta get I gotta get it together guys
Corey Orion 36 the whole Obama family
would get it I died laughing thank you
uh what else we got one couple more you
know and thanks for always thanks for
commenting please comment on the uh
Apple you know I should actually look at
those comments too right I should go to
those comments
um
you know just so people so we can get
you know the Apple podcast
yeah cause those help me out with the
algorithm too
you know you know what I mean that just
that helps me with uh
the algorithm for people watching see if
I could see some comments here uh right
let's see what we got here I don't know
if you I don't know if I can even go to
the the main page of this
let's see let's see let's see let us see
if I can go here and look at I see I
should have had this ready right
if I want to hand the thready we
wouldn't have to we wouldn't have this
issue of me like freaking looking for
the Dan the darn thing I don't know how
this works
like the the Apple podcast thing is
weird it's like you just want to go to
the the page you know but they won't
there's no way to just I just want to
click on you should be able to click on
this
and go to you know put comment or
something but there's nothing there
oh well we tried
anyways I'll have it ready for next week
so thank you for that guys all right so
anyways uh you know what there is
something going on in the news and notes
of the riffing with Griff Eric Griffin
world so
so Rachel and I went mattress shopping
and once again Janine thanks for that
um live chat let that Super Chat and
that's another way you can support the
show too I mean you know you are great
and thank you so much
uh you know that's great
[Laughter]
you know what I mean thank you so
um we went to wait I haven't I thought I
saved it
Oh I thought I saved it on on this
already let me let me actually open it
up let me
um
we wasted this we went mattress shopping
okay
Rachel and I went mattress shopping to
this um
store so you know Rachel made a big deal
out of it she was like I want us to go
um mattress shopping and I want you to
go with me you know one of these things
like your your wife you know you'll be
like just get what you want you know
what do you want you know but it's just
like I wanna it's not just about buying
something it's about the process of
going together so I carved some time out
you know I don't mind doing it it was
fun you know what I mean so we went
we went to this uh this mattress place
so she picked now I always forget that
when I tell Rachel to do stuff like this
you know when I tell her like hey can
you uh go do the thing she's gonna like
Google most expensive
mattress store near me that's what
she'll do you know
um
and so she goes we go to this place we
go to this mattress store in Santa
Monica called haste Hastings it's a
Swedish company I believe right
okay so we walk into the store you know
and it's a beautiful store it's we were
met by this sort of uh foreign guy and
I'm not sure if he was Swedish or not or
if maybe he was you know he seemed kind
of French but he seemed very European he
was dressed in a nice suit and it was
very fancy
you know there's cappuccino machine if
you need that kind of thing and he's
like oh come in and you know and you
know I'm like okay nice looking store
now I'm already ready to spend more
money on a mattress than I normally want
to okay just because sleeping properly
is important I'm starting to see that
you know so maybe the mattress might get
up to like at most I'll say six seven
thousand dollars for the mattress and
frame there okay and you know I don't
know where you are in your life but
getting a good mattress is
it is what it is okay so
we in this store and you know these what
the beds look like and I just want to
point out even on their website
there isn't a spot for
um there isn't a spot for prices like
you don't see any prices on this website
that's always a sign to me okay
so the guys showing us the beds you know
what I mean he's like yo come sit down
lay down he's put the you know the top
sheet on so you know you know what I
mean for germ's sake or whatever and
it's like the pillows are nice and he's
like different softness you know we like
we get on three different beds and and
then I actually am starting to feel what
the guy's saying he's like you know
you're supposed to be afraid to bed the
bed is supposed to conform and and
you're like oh wow yeah I really like
this one so we get on one that I'm like
oh this is the one you know he's doing
his Spiel and his talk and then Rachel's
loving it I love this bad you know and
then I say to the guy I'm laying on the
bed and I go oh this is nice I say how
much is this
oh by the way it's made of horse hair
it's made of like horse hair all-natural
organic so I said it together how much
is this and the guy says
you only have to buy this mattress this
is the only mattress you ever have to
buy in your whole entire life
I don't know what accent he was saying
but I'm not gonna try to do the accent
but the dude says this one is seventy
thousand dollars
what
he says seventy thousand and I'm like he
didn't say seventy thousand because that
would be ridiculous for a mattress okay
you hear what I'm saying that would be
ridiculous so I go no he didn't say he
said seven thousand but his accent is
messing with that he put some zeros on
it so then I then he says I go oh okay
you know I'm trying to play it cool you
get what I'm saying because I wanted to
stand up laughing his face
look at Rachel and go come on and then
walk out of there but I was like no no
let me not act a fool and then he points
to the mattress next to us and goes well
that's our beginner model right there
and that one is
51 500.
so when he said that I knew he said
70 000.
[Laughter]
for seventy thousand dollars the bed
better come with a side piece you know
what I'm saying like
seventy thousand who
what
I
so
he talks about the 51 000 one and I go
okay
um yeah thank you
um we're gonna we're still doing some
shopping we're gonna look around and see
what we like
I look at Rachel baby you ready
we get outside and I go what the hell is
wrong with you woman seventy thousand
dollars she was like well I just thought
and now she won't let it go either you
know it's one of these things she said I
love that mattress I love it you know
what I mean of course you love it it's
the best mattress I've ever laid on but
we shouldn't have laid on it because we
never gonna get it
if you can afford a seventy thousand
dollar mattress you would get three of
them you know what I mean but like for
an average can you imagine financing
your mattress
it's just
let me tell you something y'all don't
know how I wanted to get up from that
place and just be like
are you crazy
who the hell spending seven thousand
dollars on a mattress fool and stop
speaking in your dumbass accent and just
walk out of there you know what I mean
and just the coffee table I want to do
yes you know
foreign
hey more power to him I'm sure it's
worth all the money but like
damn
okay so that's
[Laughter]
man that was crazy dude that was crazy
okay so let's uh get into some stuff
here and you know what um I just want
you to know I'm considering like doing
more episodes during the week or not big
episodes even though I was clowning this
one guy who keeps telling me look you
should be doing 20 minute episodes and I
was like you don't tell me what to do
but I thought about it I was like that
actually wouldn't be such a bad thing
like if I pick like major topics that I
want to do and I put out the three you
know put out short episodes and then I'd
still do my live
you know or I combine the short episodes
also for the audio as bonus content I
don't know I'm trying to figure it out
because I like doing this and I enjoy my
little audience that comes every week I
appreciate you guys but anyways uh let's
go into like what's going on this week
let's talk about the NBA you know I
don't got no pictures of stuff to put up
but I just want to talk about it all
right so the big one is the 76ers choked
okay
now here's the thing about this seven
game series and they fired Doc Rivers
today which I'm not surprised the dude's
record in seven game sevens the dude's
record in it's the worst game seven
record by by any coach ever he's got the
worst record in closeout games by any
coach ever he's always considered to be
a player's coach and I just don't think
he has the motivation it takes to get
stars to get more out of stars he never
does that
he relies on the players you know and
and then back in the day when he had
Kevin Garnett Paul Pierce and Ray Allen
those guys were dogs like Kevin Garnett
was not going to be denied and so I you
look back on it and you realize it was
more about Kevin Garnett and those guys
than the coaching you know because they
went to seven game series three three
every layer of the playoffs that year it
was a seven game series and they were a
better team than that and they only won
one Championship so anyways and he was
gonna be fired and then they made that
trade so Doc Rivers is out again but
whatever but I'll say this
the 76ers in this seven game series won
two games
on Boston's home floor
this was a complete and utter choke job
by the Sixers
Boston's a great team but to me Jason
Tatum is too up and down I need him to
be a consistent star all the time and
he's just not that yet could be now
because of the the game he had in game
seven on his home floor he put it on his
shoulders but at the same time the six
the MVP the league Joel embiid he didn't
show up no show James Harden once again
in big moments no show no adjustments by
Doc Rivers
the Sixers lost that series the Celtics
didn't win it
in my opinion but we'll see what happens
now I do think Boston is better than
Miami I don't think Miami has enough and
it would be a real choke job for the
Sixers to lose to Miami but you know
Jimmy Butler Eric Spoelstra Pat Riley
who knows what Miami can do if they make
it to the championship what a story
right but I do think Boston's the better
team and I think they they can uh they
have enough pieces that even if they
have bad games I think they can overcome
and I think they're going to win that
series but I really thought that this
was going to be the year that Joe lmb
was going to take his team to the
championship and win but man he just
just a complete no-show it's so
disappointing so
you know and I see somebody that thinks
a stadium Tatum ain't no star that's
you're 100 wrong about that that dude is
a monster he he just doesn't have the
mentality all the time and that's what
we want to see we want to see that
killer and the dude's like six nine six
ten with handles and can shoot the
lights out I mean they do have 51 he has
the game seven playoff record now from
points in a game seven
uh in game six he had 13 or 14 points in
the fourth quarter to win that game like
that's the game the Sixers should have
won so Tatum showed up you know he
showed up you know he's a he's a star
he's just not an outgoing star you know
but he needs to be more consistent we
need consistent Star level from him we
need that Kobe Jordan LeBron he has that
Talent you know he just doesn't do it
all the time I don't know if you guys
remember that Cleveland Boston game
seven where he like dunked on LeBron
James like gave it to him you know he's
got that kind of talent man so there was
actually two dunks in these playoffs
that nobody's talking about uh what's
his name um oh what's his name Junior
from uh Denver he dunked on Kevin
Garnett bad it's crazy when stars like
that get dunked on nobody talks about it
he gave it to him and thanks for the
likes there's like a lot of you
listening right now over a hundred can
we get 100 likes that'd be nice hit me
with the likes it helps the algorithm
but anyways all right so Sixers show and
then you go over to uh the you know
Lakers did it like they're overachieving
but LeBron James is like he is
galvanizing this team and they are
really playing hard for him they beat
the brakes off of uh Golden State and
I'm glad I'm so sick of Golden State bye
I hope they break that team up I'm just
sick of them their attitude their whole
their whole thing Draymond Green and his
mouth running all the time and you know
and Jordan pool what happened to him
where are you Jordan pool which 120
million dollars like get him out they
should just trade him Klay Thompson he's
never gonna be the same player they
needed him to be Klay Thompson of old
but you just can't have an injury like
that and recover look at KD man okay
so good riddance to Golden State and
good riddance to Kevin Durant and uh in
the Suns I'm I'm so glad we don't have
to talk about them anymore it's just
like look man Kevin Durant had a
catastrophic injury he will never be the
same just face the facts okay face it
you know
if you look up oh there's this great
website
um
uh wait let me let me look it up I'm
gonna get to this website okay
you know there is this where's this oh
man what's this oh stat Muse this is a
great website man stat Muse you can just
put it you can ask any question
you can ask any question and they'll and
they'll put it up
and you know like so you go what is uh
Kevin Durant's closeout game record in
the playoffs you know
oh they're not showing it though they
did before well this is kind of weird
that they're not
they're not
um no no no I want to see career record
why aren't they showing this
anyway go to stat Muse guys they got
they got great
okay so
um
yeah you could put in like so Kevin
Durant's 21 and 12 and close out games
in his career you know
it's actually great this is a great
website for this kind of stuff but I
just want to point out like
so when you get to like
um when it was like when he was with OKC
and they were playing let's see where is
it they were playing like Miami
where is it
like when Kevin Durant was playing
Golden State in the playoffs like these
are closeout games you know it's like
the dude was like 12 for 31.
10 for third like against like when
Kevin Durant was playing gold against
Golden State and they gave up that 3-1
lead here's those his stats in the last
three games of that of the of that uh
Series so game five
closeout game they win they win the
series he's 12 for 31. all right they
lost somebody else's issue okay then it
gets serious now it's game six he's 10
for 31. you know
it's that kind of stuff and you can see
this like throughout his career man
you know what I mean like throughout his
career uh they're not showing the number
oh all the other numbers from the last
few years they got it locked for some
reason that sucks but it's like these
closeout game numbers man you just be
like what's going on anyway my point is
I know I'm doing it live so it's hard to
like you know
talk like this as I'm doing it but all
I'm saying is this the dude had a
catastrophic injury he wants to play at
the highest level and his body's gonna
fail him it's just gonna happen you
can't be 35 years old and play at a high
level in professional sports it's just
it's just it's really hard it's an
anomaly when you can do that
even LeBron James at 38 years old
he is not looking the same he's just
Savvy you know what I mean but when it
comes to like physical stuff sometimes
it's like oh he don't got it he's
missing shots or he's like he can't
defend so he's like he's just relying on
his smarts and his experience and he's
just smarter than everybody on the court
Kevin Durant is trying to out athletic
people and still do the same things that
he was doing five six seven years ago
and it's just not happening he was a
no-show in most of that series against
Denver
and I'm just so glad we don't have to
talk about that anymore like get out of
here he's done now you got Denver
I mean jokic and Murray can they do it
can they do it
we'll see they have to prove it two-time
MVP the dude had a 50-point game he's
he's a monster
but last night's game they came out and
they punched the Lakers in the mouth and
then the Lakers came back oh LeBron
James he had that three to like tie the
game and he missed it that was a huge
three and he knows it too he was like ah
but we want him taking that shot right
uh you know and then they had a costly
turnover but I think the Lakers are
gonna make the adjustment they made an
adjustment in the second half Darvin ham
is coaching his ass off dude the
adjustments he's making in game so they
made a great adjustment they put
hachimura on
um on um jokic he's big and strong kid
and then Davis was able to come over and
help on so many shots and Anthony Davis
was balling dude 40 points they just
needed everybody else to kick in and
they need to kick in earlier I think
Lakers win game two I think Lakers are
make the adjustment and they'll win game
two and then we'll see then it's all
then it's like anybody's ball game in
terms of like uh this series but I think
the Lakers have a great chance to win
this and go to the championship and win
because I think the Lakers could be any
team in the East that's left like they
can whoop Miami and they can whoop
Boston I just think that they're just
too big and strong and if I'm being
honest
I like the underdog
I really want to see LeBron James win
the championship at 38 years old I think
that would be a fantastic story it'll be
one for the ages and then the argument
about Jordan and LeBron it will be at
like at the highest it could possibly be
you know and so I look forward to that
so NBA that's great
NBA playoffs are great now let's get to
something a little more serious about
the NBA so John Moran the star Guard
from the Memphis Grizzlies he's already
got in trouble already you know if you
know remember a few months ago uh you
know he he was on Instagram at a strip
club he he had a gun and that was went
live he got in trouble for that he was
suspended eight games he had another
situation where he was in a car they say
him and his people may have been a car
and it was like a red dot going inside
the Pacers bus they thinking it was like
a on a gun
so he's like around these kind of people
that have this kind of culture there was
something else about him beating up a 17
year old so
he's starting to get this sort of bad
boy reputation at the same time he
signed a 260 million dollar deal he's
got a bunch of endorsements that he's
lost
uh you know he's trying to be the new
face the dude is a fantastic basketball
player he just is dynamic he's got a
great personality but it seems to me
that he is
got the wrong crowd around him
so once again he's in his car with one
of his boys who's doing Instagram live
and then he put he's having a good time
he's 20 something years old pulls his
gun up again pulls his gun up and you're
like what now you just go you're an
idiot that's it now I have no sympathy
for this dude I don't care about oh he's
young and he's no no no man
you lose eight games you lose out he
lost like six hundred thousand dollars
you've already lost endorsements there
is something like
seriously wrong with this dude okay
not like mental like it's just he's just
on a path that he's gonna lose it all
and then he'll look back later when he's
like 40 and be like what did I do
now a lot of people think
you put yourself in that situation
yourself your mentality your lifestyle
and you think man if I was making this
kind of money I wouldn't jeopardize it
but I reject the premise because people
think that because you get money or a
lot of money that you're somehow gonna
make the one the best decisions to the
good moral decisions because you have
money nah man that's not how it works it
just don't work like that
when you hear these professional
athletes talk especially ones that came
from like certain types of neighborhoods
a lot of them talk about how hard it was
to actually cut off people in your life
that just weren't good for you
you could be close with them these could
be your boys you grew up with but maybe
one of them got a record and you're like
yo man
listen I'm on a whole different level
now and I can't have this around me
that dude that's Instagram live in him
that knows it wasn't a surprise that
there was a gun in that car that's not
your friend
or that's the kind of friend that
doesn't care what happens to you
that's the hardest part is to remove
people from your life
that completely bring you down or don't
care about your
what's going on with you
it's hard we all have dealt with it I've
dealt with it you know what I mean I
dealt with it trust me
I know how hard it is because it's like
I'm the kind of person I'm not gonna
abandon my friends
to make you feel good
you know
you and it's like I don't need to
explain like John Moran don't need to
explain to us
why he has his friends in his life
but there comes a time that we go okay
but your friends are costing you
everything
so at a certain point he has to be an
adult and be like
like you just don't do certain things
like you come to a point you go okay I'm
gonna do this we're gonna hang you come
to the house we're gonna have barbecues
or you know we're gonna hang out like
this but we're not going to strip clubs
we're not going to go to this certain
Club we're not going to be doing in like
our life doesn't have to be online like
there's certain choices you have to make
so it doesn't mess up the money
you know what I mean
you know it doesn't mess up the money
it's like
at a certain point when you're not
concerned about that we're just watching
itself destruct you know we're what we
have to see Improvement you know
but it's like you you get it suspended
for eight games and then you you come
back and this thing happens like that's
not your friends that are around you
like you gotta have people around you
that's gonna be like hey man
um
yeah let's not like that should be a
dude that's with you that's the dude
that's like yo man turn that off
we got a gun in the car man turn off
that Instagram live you know what I'm
saying like you know like yo let's not
go live hey man you know there's got to
be like a Handler there's got to be
somebody that's not a Yes Man
because everybody right now is just like
you know you living a life imagine if
your best friend your best friend got
250 million dollars your dog the dude
you've been rolling with he's got now
you're like oh we rich that's how people
think they're like we rich y'all you
know what I mean and then you you like
yeah you know you you you love like
everybody's living the life they dreamed
but if somebody has got to be like yo
we gotta stop this
even if like it's like I'm not with him
having like like there's gun nuts out
there who are probably furious with John
Morant because they're like Yo dude
you you're just holding it where's your
where's the gun safety like you know
what I mean like this just it just
looked crazy what if the dude had to
break because it was a kid in the street
and he's got this gun and he like you
know it hits the it hits the dashboard
and the gun goes off and and and there's
some because that's what happens with
guns there's always some tragic misstep
with guns that none of that looks safe
you know what I'm saying none of it
looks safe so it's like there's so many
things wrong with what he did on top of
that
where's your people looking out for you
you know
I feel the same way about that I got the
flash star Ezra whatever all the
craziness going on with that guy just
great like he is just he has he had his
issues drugs alcohol mental whatever was
going on with him if you're his friend
why are you out with him
filming him
having a having a moment I've been
around a drunk okay I've been around a
drunk I've have close person in my life
there was a drug addict and a alcoholic
all right
I would never be filming him
filming him while he was about to do
something stupid
I don't condone any actions that that
guy did because what he did was terrible
and what his friends did is is just as
bad
[__] you filming him for while he's
getting into it with some woman and it
gets physical and you filming it
I hope that person is not in his life
anymore and I just feel like
in this car with John Morant are these
people his friends
because I feel like the sooner that
happened even the dude was like oh no
they young and stupid having a good time
in the car he's pulling up the gun like
oh I got a gun you know it's like what
are you doing
it's it's like a lack of remembering
what just happened to you and the
consequences like you know when you're a
role model you're a role model even if
you don't want to be you know and it's
just like not everyone like Charles
Barkley said in the 80s or 90s whenever
that was he was like had that commercial
he was like I am not a role model
and this is why you know but anyways uh
we can go on and on and on and let's not
but anyway that's my NBA stuff give me
your thoughts
um you know what I mean give me your
thoughts put it you know your comments
uh you know I love a good discourse uh
you know what I mean unless
see where we go from there guys but
again thanks for being here and that's
what I have to say about that all right
so let's now talk about
I saw Guardians of the Galaxy y'all
Guardians of the Galaxy oh my God I
gotta tell you this was one of the best
Marvel movies I've seen in a long time
you know
it really was it really was great
um I don't know if you guys saw it I
won't spoil it for you
I won't spoil it
but this was one of the better MCU
movies and it was a great Standalone
movie
I mean it was just emotional
you know so as you know off of the end
of end game Gamora
it's not really the one that they know
it's from the past and you know and that
must be hard I love the emotions of that
like you know imagine you know imagine
like you were pulled from the past okay
into the future
and like three or four years of a
romance it'd be like if you know it'd be
like if like before I met Rachel
and then
you know that past version it brings now
and she's like Hey we're married you
know we love each other and I'm like I
don't know you like that you know what I
mean that's got to be so hard for that
person and they really portrayed that
well like the emotions of this movie was
great James Gunn James Gunn the writer
director he's the one man he's the one
they got to keep in the MCU he's the one
that uh DC should be trying to steal
away from Marvel uh that guy's great man
this was this was such a great movie
everybody was great in there Chris Pratt
was great
um you know so then in this movie you
kind of get the origin story of Rocket
you find out how he was like you know
medically transformed into what he is
there's this great villain who's trying
to get him back and then it's just the
story of them something happens to him
and in the stories how they're trying to
save him and then just you just see this
emotions that play
uh you know throughout the whole thing
it's a great Standalone movie you don't
have to watch any other movie to
understand it uh it really was great and
everybody was great in it you know it
just it like the emotions of this was
great you might even cry in this and you
just you cheer
um a fantastic movie man it really was
and I just hope that they continue in
this because
I wanted to talk a little bit about like
where I think the MCU is going I don't
really like it I'm not excited about it
I think all these movies are so
disjointed they're not really connected
uh and then and they're not great like
I'm fine with a movie not being great if
it's telling if it has a purpose for the
story
that's coming but you know what we don't
know
maybe the eternals is going to help tell
a story that's coming uh it's a terrible
movie uh maybe you know this last Thor
not very good not my favorite Thor
um you know all of these movies that
we've seen in the last three or four
years since end game you know that the
the shangshi uh whatever that one is the
Asian one you know it's like
what's that one is that one somehow uh
how are they all connected but you know
it's not all been bad Loki's been great
I love Loki and I'm sure that weaves
into the story I didn't see Ant-Man yet
I just didn't I I don't know I just
didn't want to see it so I'll wait for
that to come on but so I don't know
where the MCU is going and it might come
all come together and people will be
like oh this all makes sense now
because I hear there's two more Avengers
movies coming out so we'll see we'll see
if they get it all together and it all
makes sense you know Dr the doctor
strange movie you know how does it all
come together and coalesce into this
like thing that that they did before
that they just did better before I
thought I thought leading up to the
Avengers you know because not all the
Avengers movies were great like Age of
Ultron you know get out of here with
that one you know you know what I mean
so not all the movies were great but
they led to something and then there was
some you there's like some outstanding
movies
in the road to Avengers you know Civil
War was one of the best Marvel movies uh
that one was great
um the one uh uh um um what's the what's
the the one arm guy that movie uh you
know the sil he's in Civil War it's
about him
um Bucky whatever his name is the why am
I I always forget things whatever that
guy that movie
those that was a great movie too I
didn't like uh the first Captain America
I thought that was trash I didn't like
Iron Man 3. they just ignored Iron Man 3
like it didn't even exist right and I
don't know what happened to that
technology of healing it could have
saved Tony Stark but they just kind of
removed it from the universe where it
doesn't exist so you know what I'm
saying so there was a couple of Duds in
there that led to just what was probably
one of the greatest accomplishments in
movie history to me is leading up to
so uh the two Avengers movies that was
just fantastic you know what I mean it
just that was just great what a payoff
it was just Winter Soldier thank you the
Winter Soldier yeah that was a great
movie so leading up to Avengers was
great so maybe they're gonna do it again
but this was a good start a good middle
one of the great movies in this next
phase of Marvel so I don't know if you
saw it I do recommend it I give it 10
woo-woos
[Music]
great movie
oh
you know what I didn't want to talk
about this I want no I did I wanted to
talk about this last week right and I
didn't get to talk about it but I want
to talk about it now I didn't I didn't
put it in the notes but I'm gonna say it
now
man I saw
Peter Pan
and Wendy Rachel and I are watching it
we do this thing where while we're
eating we'll pick some movie and we'll
watch it and then we'll stop when we
finish eating and then we'll pick it
back up right so she wanted to watch
Peter Pan and Wendy
I'm of the belief now that
companies that
they feel so guilty about their past
that they're over compensating now
man
oh man Peter Pan and Wendy is a classic
over correction of what's going on in
society right now
it is literally one of the worst movies
I've ever seen right but it's also the
funniest like
diversity movie
okay so I almost want to go through the
whole movie like how I do my movie
things but I'm not gonna do it today but
I might do it another time but just real
briefly this is this is what it lets you
know uh oh
so the movie starts off with a
mid-century white family okay and you go
okay Disney you keep it in 100. this is
the kind of families that were around in
in England or wherever they are
it's a regular ass white family dad the
mom two sons a daughter obviously she's
Wendy and they're you know the kids are
playing it's just one of those like
she's about to go to boarding school
it's one of those where you go okay this
is this is time this is like you know
time correct you know what I mean you're
like okay
then
black Tinker Bell shows up
right so black Tinkerbell shows up and
you watch it and you go here we go you
know I got no problem with fictional
characters being any race I'm fine with
it actually like if you're somebody
that's upset about that you're an idiot
like it doesn't matter right it's just
funny but it's just funny because you
know you can feel the diversity meeting
when you watch Disney movies now you can
feel that this was a discussion and it's
like there's no Artistic integrity in
this none there's no Artistic integrity
in it and it's just like people watching
it no you're just making everybody
uncomfortable because you've been
terrible for a hundred years so black
Tinkerbell shows up
and then
ambiguous race Peter Pan comes flying in
and then you know okay
we on a ride now we on the diversity
roller coaster let's go
then they get to Neverland and it's just
a hodgepodge of these kids as black kids
Asian kids white kids with glasses a kid
with Down Syndrome you're like all right
so is this winter keeping all these kids
in the universe they're like these kids
don't have they don't get families
they're just on the neverland Island
it's so crazy
I go all right man it just kind of feels
like they were sitting around like do
you guys see what good people we are at
Disney we are such tremendous human
beings we have a kid with Down Syndrome
on Neverland he's in charge it's like
that's how it feels
now we're living through the over
correction right now so right now it's
so like whoa what is this hopefully in
10 years it will be normalized and we
won't even think about it you know we'll
see interracial couples we'll see mixed
race couples we'll see you know people
doing things and we'll just kind of be
like oh this is a great story and
there'll be some Artistic integrity but
right now there is none and we're
watching and we're going we don't like
it
so bad on IMDb that they stopped letting
people
leave not on IMDb uh what's the One
Rotten Tomatoes
it's so bad on Rotten Tomatoes that
they're not letting people leave reviews
anymore
it's got an 11
audience score
idiots who again these are also people
who are like we are we're gonna show you
that we care about diversity and we're
gonna you know this one 61 percent
Rotten Tomatoes score it's like
it's crazy
okay that's
that's all I'll say about that
all right so what else is going on
um crazy stories in the world man let's
go over this crazy stories in the world
the weekend
the weekend I I don't know what's going
on with this dude man
but the weekend has said
he's going by his birth name Abel
tesfaye I don't even know if I'm even
saying that right test Faye you know
somebody's tell me after saying he wants
to kill the weekend right
this guy he's an artist man he one of
these like he he's a he's an artsy
fartsy type dude I can tell because I
remember when the weekend first came out
he had that crazy hair you know what I
mean and then that was his signature
look and we we Associated this really
great pop music that we liked with this
guy's look and they combined and we were
like oh I like this but then
he cut his hair and he talks about how
all the people around him you know like
the you know people that make money off
him were like dude you can't cut your
hair that's your thing you know he was
like nah that's not my thing I'm a great
you know and he cut his hair now in my
opinion I haven't paid attention to him
since you know but I'm old uh you know I
couldn't even tell you a weekend song
you know when he was at the Super Bowl I
was like oh okay oh that's the weekend
song you know like you know what I mean
like
but I respect
his process of being like nah I want to
do this I want to be known for being an
artist
but it's like
you're gonna kill the weekend like
at a certain point this is the music
business it's also entertainment like if
you just want to be an artist then go
live in a commune in the middle of
Wyoming where you could just make your
art but if your art is about
selling something then you gotta also
play the game a little bit
I think this is too far I think this
whole like it's gonna be a kind of a
trip where we just kind of go hey man I
just want to turn on Spotify and listen
to some great songs I don't want to be a
part of your whatever the hell is going
on with you psychologically can you deal
with that on your own because we don't
want to deal with it there is a part of
that that's a fair
you know what I mean like that's a fair
feeling that you might be feeling of
being like okay what's your name now
because we don't really care can I just
listen to your songs so we'll see how it
all plays out maybe when it's all said
and done and he's 50 60 years old he's
getting inducted into the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame we'll look back and be like
whoa this guy went on a journey like
Prince you know Prince went on a big
Journey or changing his name and for you
know legal reasons with the music and he
had different styles and genres and
we'll look back and be like wow what a
tremendous artist so maybe that's what
will happen but as you're living through
it you're kind of like
you know what I mean what are you saying
uh weekend so I thought that one was
weird
another weird story that's going on is
this is crazy y'all so
this person
had a butt plug
in
and went to go get an MRI
and there was metal in the butt plug
and it flew
into up
into their body and now they're suing
did suing the butt plug people
because
the butt plug had a metal core but and
the butt plug accelerated at the speed
of sound into the client's chest cavity
wow
I mean
you know when you leave in the house
and you're thinking about all the things
you need to put on like I'm a hat guy
now so I'm like okay let me let me get
my keys let me get my wallet
um let me get my hat you know what I
mean Which hat should I wear okay you
get to the door and you like oh I didn't
put in my butt plug
I gotta go get my butt plug
and then you like you know you open up
your assortment of butt plugs you know
what I mean because you're on the way to
get your MRI too by the way like I'm
like I'm going to get my MRI okay I got
my hat my kids my wallet
um didn't eat anything they just said
not to eat anything
so I probably shouldn't eat anything
because I don't want them to see and you
walking at you like I like my but I
gotta have my butt plug in
so you go get your butt plug
put your butt plug in and then you go
get your MRI
or how about this maybe it's even worse
you forgot
the butt plug was in like damn how
comfortable is this butt plug
that's a crazy story so that's my crazy
stories of the week
last but not least American Idol y'all
you know I love American Idol
I am real listen I've watched American
Idol for a long time I was already
shocked two weeks ago when they let go
the redhead country dude and the young
17 year old girl I'm telling you right
now every year they have a tremendous 16
15 16 17 year old girl who reminds you
of Taylor Swift Billy eilish Vibe right
and they and America kicks her out they
go yeah we don't want you and they keep
so when they kicked her out I was like
oh no they kicked her out they kicked my
favorite guy out Oliver Stone but his
confidence was shaking we felt it I
might have him on my podcast because I
talked to him on Instagram I was trying
to hump pump him up man I was like you
could do it man you're the best you know
but unfortunately he's a great dude and
he's got a great music so he's gonna
have a great career all right so of
these people that's left these five I
already knew what was happening
and when I saw these five I watch
American Idol enough to know black girl
gone she was getting kicked out
chubby white guy gone he was getting
kicked out
I knew it was gonna be white country boy
white country girl and the fat guy
because he's the most lovable he's got a
Milky voice now it's those three left
it's the three on the left there uh
Colin style
um the girl what's her name
um
oh man I forgot oh here we go here we go
let me get her name I knew this guy was
gonna get kicked out the girl's gonna
get Colin style Megan Danielle voice of
an Angel this chick has sing and I am I
am I am tongue like I'm telling you
right now
you heard it here first Colin style is
gonna win American Idol cause that's who
wins American Idol the moment I saw him
get through over better singers
better country singer I was like
for sure going to win American Idol
y'all just you heard it here first okay
I just this is what happens I would be
shocked if he didn't win
second is going to be the girl okay like
like she's just great she country but
again I would not be surprised if they
kick her off first
for some reason an American Idol
audience does not like women anymore you
know they got Carrie Underwood you got
the you know what's her name uh from the
beginning there's a few women throughout
history that they've picked for whatever
reason back in the Simon days but
recently there's been some women who
have tremendous voices that do not win
so it is what it is
the people that watch American Idol in
the middle of the country they love them
some white boys with guitars
this kid's good though I'm not gonna I'm
not slighting the guy the dude is good
there's been in the past I will say
there's been a few guys that have won
Roz like there's no way that guy should
have won over whoever the ethnic singer
whatever person was that that one time
it was just ethnic girl she was so
[__] she was so good he no way he was
a better singer than her right he won
there's been times like that that it's
happened right I I will not be shocked
if any I'll be shocked if I am wins if
the the lovable
uh you know Samoan kid wins that would
be a shocker but I just feel like middle
of America
that watches American Idol live on their
regular TV with the bunny rabbit ears
they're voting for Colin style so
that's who's gonna win American Idol you
heard it here first
all right y'all what a show huh we just
you know we just did it just pop pow pow
took care of it no issues this week
right I love it you know it work it
works like that sometimes so my boy
fishy
um you know I downloaded his things but
let me just go to this
he
he sent me some beats and if you want to
send some beats and by the way thanks
for watching we're from with Griffin you
know as we're here every single week you
know I appreciate y'all ripping with
Griffin make sure you subscribe you know
share wait where where is the how come I
can't find this man it's so annoying oh
here he is Fisher
you know so uh yeah and then you know
I'm on Twitch which I'm on Twitch most
days so come check me out there and you
know subscribe to me on patreon you know
what I mean
so you know what time it is y'all
it's that time again where we hit that
rap recap
yo yo yo yo yo got the new beat got the
new B
all written
week Griffin Guardians of the Galaxy you
should go see
check it out American Idol
pulling Style
he gonna win that crowd
on the NBA
what can I say
just they didn't slay they got slayed
LeBron James trying to do his thing he
might win
one more ring
and we do it all the way through it here
we go
hang it up
Eric
Griffin
[Music]
move your feet here we go all right
y'all
not one of fishy's better beats but
watching we're from with Griffin and I
will see you next week
peace